hey everybody and welcome back to koalas
ooh wow I forgot which episode this was
but today I'm gonna work on a hotel
building which is kind of a very new
venture for the zoo but it's gonna fit
in somewhere in the lower left corner on
the map and I'm building this on a
separate map as always because my
computer is totally dying even thinking
of opening the actual koalas little map
at this point but anyway I've got some
guests the introduce as always lady and
Rudy are here as well hello hello I was
about to say good evening but I don't
know which time it is for the people so
take whatever you want okay good day yes
good Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
whatever day is do you guys ever think
of like randomly in your videos saying
like very specific things that any
viewer can just randomly pick up on like
I know you're watching this on a Tuesday
and then everybody was like yeah I did
this once with the skipping I just
checked my videos and just looked where
the people usually skip to like which is
the average time they skip to and then
just plug that into the video and said
hey I saw you skipping here and I got
like I don't know at least 30 comments
saying damn you just caught me exactly
in that second yeah I think I I think
you actually caught me with that one
time I vaguely remember seeing this as
well it's quite a few times yeah that's
really cool
it's it's a great thing to put like at
the end of your video when you get into
the cinematics and you just notice that
everybody watches that stuff like skips
to it from halfway through the video
that's true that's true just but the
funny part as a as a viewer you really
feel caught and that's so that kind of
is so engaging because like hey Andy
thinks about that what's going on here
so yeah oh man Soph what's going on I
can already see there is something
growing okay that sounds wrong but we
are talking about architecture
yes this is this is surely your opening
line in the bedroom in it we get even
less so I'm working on this thing right
and I was for a while actually I've been
planning to build a hotel in this
specific spots because quality shoe is a
big company qawalli
in general is a big like venture
capitalist holding or whenever it is and
sort of going with the times zoos are
becoming more and more like theme parks
and this this zoo is already quite large
and has lots of different facilities
that maybe not every zoo has and a hotel
just feels like the right thing to add
to it especially considering that koala
Beach also had a very big like stay at
the premises kind of deal with the Bora
Bora Hut's by karelis which were really
cool it's gonna be hard to live up to
just how cool of a stay that would be
because honestly these buildings aren't
really gonna be as interesting as hotel
rooms I think you've been in paradise
huh yeah oh yeah paradise are super cool
like on-site premises where you can stay
at have you actually seen those lady
I've seen I've seen some pictures yeah
and I was like oh my god just imagine
sleeping and at the other side of your
window you have like a walrus or like a
polar bear just swimming while you are
in your bedroom like what oh my god I
really want to experience that once I
love to I'm just gonna Monte yeah
crashing into your hotel room awesome oh
my god Koreans but it's it's really deep
polar bear or walrus as far as I know
maybe a few are there animals so so what
I do know is I haven't stayed at any of
their like hotel rooms or
or kind of deals but I've been in the
zoo and have like basically seen all of
them because they're really in the park
like in that case it's not even like
there's a hotel just outside the zoo
where you maybe have a cool view now
it's really in the middle of all the
habitats so well there's one kind of
exception in the North American section
which is the newest section and which is
where they have all of these hotels and
like on-site stay things they do have
one large building next to the seals or
the sea lions somewhere in that corner
which is just all hotel rooms kind of
deal so that is more standard but then
they also have at the wolf and bear
enclosure they have rooms which are have
just a window between you and the wolves
and the Bears which is just super cool
it's also a combined habitat so you get
to see different animals as well and
those things actually remind me a lot
yeah I just saw the images yeah that's
really I have no cool it's so they have
a hill honestly they have a hill and
like the houses are inside this hill you
go into it like like a house from The
Hobbit and on the other side this is the
window where you can just have direct
eye sights with the animals as you're
like yeah I just saw that picture of the
hotel I think we need to do a planet so
you meet up there honestly sounds like a
really cool yeah really cool I really
didn't know it until like last week that
they had this because I know a lot of
people from the community would love to
go to Paradise avid for me personally
it's just a little bit too far away but
if you can say there like that is just
yes that is incredible yeah yeah I love
it
I really I mean even though I have to
say it's also a bit scary you know
considering you sleep there and you know
that kind of a I don't know how much
does a normal grizzly bear weight or
whatever it's just leaping like if I
kind of 10 feet away from you on the
other
of the glass I mean I had that kind of
you know I I am kind of Brent mocked on
that side because I've been sleeping
quite next to a freakin alligator in
Miami so not want to do this again right
that's honestly it's it's just a like
when I've been eight years old we've
been to Miami and we stayed in a hotel
that was basically just next to a road
but they had all these signs like do not
feed the alligator and blah blah blah
and no one really took that seriously
and one night I just got awake and we
had a room together with my parents my
brother and me and I had that bat right
next to the front door which was also
like a double side glass very like I
think it was even like a structure the
glass to be very safe and stuff now we
know why and then I just got awake and I
just turned around and there was this
freakin alligator just on the other side
just next to that glass all on the
street it's completely that was so crazy
and yeah my dad was already awake he was
at the back of the room and she's also
pretty pretty pretty shocked so yeah
this is also my I think this might be a
bit frightening but no it's actually
really cool I will you know I think if
they offer these rooms they have
potentially thought about the security
yeah pretty sure like six sided glass or
something strong as well how you say it
double glass I don't know it's security
glass six way secure whatever yeah
probably some air yeah I don't know
whatever
yeah bulletproof make sense yeah so but
did you use inspiration for the for the
hotel you're building here no so this is
I have to say this is just a separate
hotel honestly there aren't really any
habitats right now in Kamali's ooh that
I think you could combine with something
like this because you know if you do you
really have to include it from the
ground up you know in the end of it set
designs because really impiety dizer
that's where it starts like these
habitats are completely designed with
these hotel rooms in mind so
for the the wolves and the Bears for
instance you have this Ridge with the
rooms in it and then on top of it you
have the walkway where you can actually
see the animals and then on top of that
they also have some chicken coops I'm
not entirely sure why but yeah they're
just a few random small chicken coops in
there as well I thought that was really
funny but yeah that's one of the places
that you can stay there's also a habitat
with deer in it where you can stay in
like small houses which is obviously
less you know dangerous if you will in
terms of the animals but the deer do
freely roam around your house so they
could like sit on your porch at least I
think they're deer I'm not entirely sure
but yeah this is all yeah this is all
like the North American area of the
point wow it really sounds like I have
to go that way I really want to I mean I
I just have to say that we are not
sponsored by PI D dies but if my god
just named that episode you guys are
talk yeah this this this hotel is very
different from that is really just a
standalone building so yeah it's not
quite as special but I'm still trying to
you know make sure that it fits into the
rest of the map and honestly I have to
struggle a bit to get into this oh yeah
yeah a little bit of a custom roof just
because I needed to get this triangular
thing poking out of the front entrance
where I died you know we had these
pieces exactly in the game with the
tattoo amazing you would not use it but
we have these kind of pieces yeah that's
true and they're super good and like
exactly the kind of pieces that we need
for the whole koala theme
yeah different textures yeah exactly but
honestly this this whole style of the
building is already really cool and the
one thing you are delivering here I
think is really great this really hotel
is feel and vibe to it you know this you
know at first is just kind of really
tall rise building you know you look at
but you have this kind of Lobby appeal
by this awning all kind of roof
stitching out and it still looks super
cool with those roofs and central tower
is this gonna be having an elevator in
the center yeah so like the the general
plan for this building for me was
actually that this is kind of just a
wing on the side like the actual
reception or restaurant or things like
that I don't really have space for so
the central tower is realistically where
the staircases would be in the elevators
I think it helps to like hide the
elevator shafts because elevators always
stick out at the top of a building and I
am trying to make this building you know
in a kind of postmodern sense resemble
the traditional Indonesian architecture
with those angled roofs so it would be
hard to fit an elevator in that kind of
building but this this main sort of
middle tower helps also hide what would
be elevator shafts so yeah that's the
general layout just the simple you know
wing building elevators and stairs in
the middle and then window frames oh
yeah I'm so glad that we have these
stucco pieces and the separate glass
pieces in the game now okay like any
window you can you can dream of you
could pretty much make it pretty easily
so many pieces you know it's not like
putting 20 gems in one window again I
don't know who would ever do is in what
game but I mean at the end of the day by
the end of this episode
this building has just over 4,000 pieces
in total so it's a lot but it's also
very big building with a reasonable
amount of detail so honestly it's less
pieces than I thought at first it would
have but you have you've made two
different hotels right or assists you
only one yeah this is the only one you
can actually see the other one in the
background but are you re not gonna use
that one I think I won't honestly the
way that it went was I started out with
the other
one because the plan that I had in the
first place was to make a very tall
building but then I built that and it
didn't really feel like it fits inside
the zoo
obviously the hotel building was going
to be visible from the rest of the zoo
because it's a really tall building so
you're gonna have some sight lines and I
try to work out a little bit from where
you can see it but I feel like the glass
style just didn't really work out that
well in the zoo so I ended up switching
to this style instead you could just see
the modern building in the back and
maybe there could be a use for that kind
of thing one day but for now personally
I think this fits a lot better in the
zoo oh yeah I definitely like this style
of it it looks beautiful but I also
really liked the other building you
showed some pictures of it for those who
don't know and think that I'm just
judging from the back it really looks
gorgeous I really like it's very modern
but this also yeah it looks very nice
okay just point it now yeah let me just
point out how clever that is using those
circles to have these shape perfect
shapes you lazy man but yeah oh my god
this is very clever and I love the way
how you did these I was like wondering
if you build some small huts here you
know because like the resort field kind
of has this in mind as well but you know
sylph was going to do only kind of
guidance to make a custom like I could
guess could be a pool or maybe a huge
planter um yeah so it's it's almost the
pool it's not actually gonna be a pool
it's gonna be sort of a centerpiece the
way that I was imagining this is it's
gonna be a sort of compound of different
buildings surrounding one central area
so you have the big tower with all the
apartments and then attached to that
will be a building with the reception
and restaurants and like other kinds of
facilities which is a much lower rise
building and then you can have some
gardens on one side or gazebo or you
know other kind of
Sylla teas and things and maybe even a
section with small houses where you can
rent one house or something I am not
entirely sure how it's gonna go but I
wanted to have some sort of like central
area where you can come back to and
where everything connects and that's
what this is going to be just the
central kind of water elements it's
gonna have some bridges over it as well
and lots of foliage around it even
bridges that's so cool
that is so amazing so really it looks
absolutely gorgeous I just I love the
shape of it and I I just I tried to
remember how our hotel was called on
Hawaii because actually the exact same
thing as you were describing that was
our hotel exactly this way on Hawaii it
had this two central tower you know with
all the all the big rooms and adults of
the Suites and then you had like the
central area with the pool and stuff and
then attached to it there was like a
gold of course and around the golf
course you had all these huts you know
where you could have like a little bit
cheaper and low-rise area right
oh my god this is so good yeah and I
guess the the thing is this water over
here because I did base the idea on you
know just looking at pictures of resorts
and how they're usually laid out and
where this water is is realistically
where the pool would kind of be in a lot
of these resorts the problem is that
this is not in the backside yeah that's
that's what I was thinking the problem
is that this is like totally the place
where you arrive from inside the park so
it would be weird to like have the pool
in front of the building from where you
arrive from inside the park so ideally
there could be a pool in this you know
in the next episode because that's this
episode is already getting too long but
if there would be a pool it's gonna be
in the back I know someone who can make
hmm that's it
I know I know I know because it's really
cool obviously you can't use it but it's
really awesome I really love that it's
very poor I mean I think we have the
basic pieces for it because the same
like round border pieces that I use for
this central water elements here could
definitely be used to make a pool as
well yep
maybe with a few modifications but it
should be good oh definitely oh my god
oh yeah and this is this is where most
of the pieces went not a custom loop no
custom walls or anything I just wanted
this pavement it's not of these little
tiles but this there are more pieces now
then there will be because I'm of course
trying to work around these corners but
yeah I wanted the path to like
completely hug all of the corners and
these curves everywhere so it has to be
custom it just has to be and then there
will be an in-game one underneath this
one oh they just love so incredible they
look just so incredible it's really just
using my words I'm sorry about the the
piece counts but it's just this this
little texture is also too good I was
scrolling through the items thinking you
know what could you build a part out of
then I haven't tried before and just the
backside of these South American pieces
just has such a nice texture that you
can recolor just to have some variety in
it for me personally the thing that also
helps a lot is the fact that you don't
see the tanks to repeat as much if you
build a really big square out of like
in-game floor pieces you can see the
texture really repeating and you could
just start seeing all these little
squares all around it and in this case I
slightly change the color of some of the
tiles and just kind of randomly you know
rotated these big swaths of paths around
so you don't really see a repeating
pattern and I know it's a really small
thing no that's cool
like that as extra detail but you you
really tackled a good point here this is
let the randomized texture and
randomized seamless texture one I would
love to see frontier introducing that in
maybe a future stage of the cobra engine
because like I don't know if you guys
are familiar with that like usually how
textures work is that you have this
texture tile which is normally a square
and then you have all the sides all four
sides are seamlessly connected to each
other so that you can attach this to all
sides and it always creates a seamless
kind of connection to each other that's
how it usually works but there is also a
way now a more modern way where like an
algorithm has and let's say like 4 8 12
16 whatever variants of it and then it
kind of has different textures in it
that all works seamlessly together but
overall they create a way bigger pattern
until you see the repetitive texture to
it
so basically you just adding one more
file or two more files and you just get
getting like am whatever found more
variations in it and especially for not
maybe maybe not for walls and pieces but
for like a landscaping and and ground
texture that would be awesome
or like pathways for example because
this is something that I really would
love to see especially because I think
planets do and ultimately closer were
built on a more smaller scale the more
you zoom in that the more great the
detail becomes but if you zoom out a
little bit it gets a bit more repetitive
yeah that's true
if you zoom out build its its some plans
really tend to be like super fake as if
you're on the lowest quality like very
quick just sad sometimes just doesn't
look like a plant anymore if I wanna
make I mean that's also safe performance
yeah yeah question like what is the
effect on performance but oh my god
having random nice textures and this is
yeah well there is a little bit of a
debate going on because the modern
graphics can't basically have no effect
on that because they have a bigger like
bigger RAM and stuff where I can I'm not
like an expert on that but at least what
I got from from what I was reading they
have more threats to load them in and
basically
once this is once this is loaded they
kind of combined them together and since
the overall quality of it is the same
and it doesn't matter if it is texture a
or B it always depends on how many
pieces you would lay down or how big the
area is you know what I mean if the JPEG
file of version one is like let's say I
don't know 200 kilobytes and you have
like 200 of them it's the same as if you
have like 100 of file a or file B and
both of them F 200 kilobytes because in
combination they have the same amount
right kilobytes to load in and to
display you know what I mean so it's
mostly fine you're saying yeah yeah it's
mostly fine it just is it's a file more
to load but that's just once you know
one go and then it's done it doesn't
have to load them in all the time
because it's not randomized but speaking
of which frontiers showed that they seem
to be experimenting with stuff like that
with for example the dynamic texture on
the rocks the jungle rocks for example
so yeah let's see if they are working on
something like that yeah sounds really
cool but this pool man if you make more
use of this trick of making circles and
just putting them everywhere and
connecting the circles and moving the
like bits that are left over because
honestly it's surprisingly easy and not
that time-consuming to do and just
looking at these smooth curves going
everywhere and putting some plants in
the middle of it it's just a really nice
way to you know finish up an area like
this especially because of course I
wanted this pond in the middle to look
completely artificial but at the same
time what I have a lot of foliage around
it and not have it just be a boring
square so I think it's a nice middle
ground oh wow it's definitely not a
that's true but I'm really questioning
if that should become a pool because it
looks so beautiful and as it is meant to
be there maybe we have to have a
separate pool we do have some space
there so that shouldn't be an issue also
considering the fact that everyone can
just look down into the pool area from
the hotel and it's kind of annoying for
the people privacy wise I mean okay
you're on a resort what about
privacy anyways but it it's it's kind of
I don't know it's just too beautiful to
think about changing this I guess it's
yeah that's awesome like it's awesome if
it were me I wouldn't be able to have as
much of this foliage around it and I
have the same kind of planter situation
going on
and I really just wanted to have that
all but honestly at the back of the
hotel on the other side I think the pool
would be really well suited to be there
mm-hmm yeah I guess so that really looks
good to make to leave this area as it is
because it just looks really awesome
and man I'm so gonna steal this circular
trick I'm so gonna steal that it's an
amazing way to create plant area
I was already I was already thinking why
you took so many small pieces for these
circular things but now obviously that
makes sense to be able to delete them
all pretty yeah it's a lot of pieces
honestly you could do it with bigger
pieces as well for me the thing is just
I wanted these curves to be as smooth as
possible and be able to like change the
heights as easily as possible as well so
they're all made out of little cubes
which is a bit much should have probably
used pillars instead but oh well it is
what it is now also you thought off the
people disabled people in the ICU of
course that's really good many people
will be yeah reason I've got these
planters do you pleasure to freak me out
it's like yeah it's this is going to be
like the main sort of importance area
for this whole situation here this is
where the restaurant will be and then
hopefully a small area with some you
know parasols outside and a seating area
and stuff this is gonna have to come in
later episodes because this episode is
already becoming too long honestly at
first I was hoping that I could make
this thing in one episode it's just yeah
it's not gonna happen but yeah this is
where the restaurant and everything is
gonna be and then it's gonna connect
through the big you know building with
the rooms as well on the side there
and welcome to the booty dimension not
being able to do this because you
started to do too much hello yeah lady
knows the same so it's kind of lolli as
well so much you try to like have one
certain topic for when you try to finish
it didn't want to go but then once
you're building you're just like oh but
I could add this and I should add this
and that's not quite where it should be
and then things just quickly just smile
and of control do you need more time to
work on it but this is like how the east
games work right I I remember that I
said at the beginning of my ongoing
project okay I made the mistake in in
the planet coaster times that I kind of
worked too long on one area and you know
I had like involved videos about one
area for example hey you know I have to
do it like one-off builds and I I think
I managed to do this like for 10
episodes and then I was gone you just
can not do this because some projects
are just too big to fit them in one
episode even if you cut even if you
speak too crazily so for example polar
bear habitat can't be doing it can be
done it I mean technically well
technically you don't have to record
anything you just finish a whole zoo and
I only record the zoo tour I'll just
keep it for yourself and enjoy it
yourself just you know sit at home and
say well done lady and then delete it
and start over again
I imagine god this is though actually I
mean like the end of the day my god I
think even if you are like making videos
as a youtuber you should always build
things just out of your own enjoyment
and if not for that then why are you
really doing it
so definitely yeah like being able to
just build something for yourself and
not even know whether anybody else is
gonna see it but just enjoy the process
that's the best and most important
feeling I think of playing these kinds
of games yep alright so yeah that
already
geez we did it we did it yeah yeah yeah
sort of what paradise ah so do you have
cinematics or that's a really good point
I'm actually I'm gonna and we're gonna
record a few but for you guys okay okay
so you're gonna watch that's huh that's
fine ah sin again you're gonna have to
yes you're gonna have to skip to the end
and then I'll add a little voice clip
saying oh you skip to the end
god no you're really doing it no I'm not
gonna add that one in but yeah I'm gonna
have to see what I can do but to be fair
this is just a very unfinished project
so I'm not too happy to show it off yet
but next time hopefully in the next
episode then I'm gonna work on this I'll
be able to finish it and it's gonna look
like a cool resort it definitely doesn't
look very promote to itself very
promising
oh god so who's next actually I think
it's me yeah no no I stay I'm here I'm
okay I don't go anyway I would have gone
to Greece actually well yeah today today
17 minutes in today
but no obviously we can't so when we
stay at home yeah that's that's how it
is so do you have the week off then yes
I have I do
so time I have well yeah we just talked
and we just talked briefly before the
episode so potentially I'm really going
to touch the safari tour maybe not just
as a start but yeah I gonna have to talk
to mr. Mike then because I then have to
know what he's doing was the lady's
backside of the reptile house so that's
gonna be very interesting yeah yeah be
excited next week will be good alright
sounds like you have something to work
on mm-hmm you know I'm not bored why
it's fine
Oh God awesome oh my god it's all of you
this look what gorgeous oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah but shall we wrap it up
because I don't know how long you want
to okay I have no idea I'm just gonna
drag out the time-lapse that's cool but
yeah we're really gonna have to wrap it
up here we're not gonna say anything
useful anymore at this point honestly so
yeah thanks everybody for watching this
video I hope you enjoyed I'm sorry by
the way for uploading this a week late
honestly last week I totally got rekt by
school stuff and I mismanaged my time
management a lot but yeah I'm back on
track and really looking forward to
finishing this build and I hope you guys
enjoy it as well also thank you lady and
Rudy for being here with me yeah thanks
thanks for having us no problem and I
guess we'll see each other all next week
onwards you know yeah bye bye guys bye
everybody